I'm talking about I am talking about how  as a female to be as attractive as  possible to men now I'm not saying you  can't get a man if you say another car  I'm saying how do you be as ATT  attractive as possible because you're  all about it because you also don't  understand how men think it's different  if you come to my house and choose to  like another one of my cars but what if  I only have one car and now you say well  no I picked up my BMW oh yeah it's nice  I prefer Mercedes you know what man  thinks the second you say that who  picked you up in a Merc that's the first  thing that goes to his [ __ ] mind who  how do you know about Mercedes  the man's mind I'm telling you how men  think